انسحبت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من مدينه
رام الله بعد مداهمتها لبنايه سكنيه في حي
المصايف وفاد مراسلون ان قوات الاحتلال
اقتحمت شقه سكنيه في البنايه وقامت
بتفتيشها والعبث بمحتوياتها كما حصرت
بنايات سكنيه بالقرب من هيئه الاذاعه
والتلفزيون الفلسطيني
بالمدينه
فلسطين والله العظيم في
اعتقال ينضم الينا من رام الله مراس
الجزيره محمد خيري محمد اذا اطلعنا على ما
جرى في رام
الله نعم قبل قليل فقط انسحبت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بعدما داهمت هذه
الشقه السكنيه في هذه العماره هنا في حي
عين مصباح في مدينه رام الله يمكنكم
مشاهده حجم الدمار والتخريب الذي حل بهذه
الشقه بعدما اقتحمتها قو قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي حتى الجدران تم العبث فيها
وتخريبها كما تشاهدون وا يعني شهود عيان
افادوا بسماع اصوات من داخل
الشقه ما يدل على انه ربما جرت هنا عمليه
اعتقال ولكن لا بيانات رسميه ولا شهود
يؤكدون هويه هذا المعتقل
الذي اخذته قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من
هذه الشقه السكنيه لكن واضح جدا ان قوات
الاحتلال سعت الى تدر تدمير وتخريب
محتويات هذه الشقه السكنيه والبحث داخل
حتى جدران هذه الشقه السكنيه الشهود عيان
قالوا لي انهم سمعوا فعلا صوت صراخ ما
ربما قد يشير الى اعتداء قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي على احد الفلسطينيين الذي ربما
كان داخل هذه الشقه السكنيه اثناء عمليه
الاقتحام ويعني بعض الدلائل تشير الى انها
كان يعني الى ان بعض الامور لا تبدو تبدو
فعليا جديده ما يعني ان
هناك بعض الساكنين كانوا داخل هذه الشقه
السكنيه على الرغم من المصير غير الواضح
حتى هذه
اللحظه كما تشاهدون جميع غرف وزوايا هذه
الشقه السكنيه تعرضت الى ال تدمير
والتخريب من قبل قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
التي لم تترك زاويه الا وفتشتها وخربتها
داخل هذه الشقه السكنيه اذا كما قلنا
انسحبت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فعليا
قبل قليل من هنا مخلفه وراءها هذا ال
الدمار الذي تشاهدونه ثم اقتحمت القوات
بعد ذلك العماره المقابله لهذه العماره
السكنيه وهناك اعتلت سطح العماره م
وفتشت
السطحى ثم قال شهود عيان انها يعني حملت
بعض الامور الى داخل حامله الجند فعليا
خمسه اليات عسكريه اسرائيليه اقتحمت هذه
العماره وكذلك كانت ترافقها حامله جند
اسرائيليه الى جانب ذلك هناك اقتحام واسع
من قبل قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في هذه
الاثناء لمدينه نابلس شمالي الضفه الغربيه
القوا قوات الاحتلال اقتحمت مدينه نابلس
من محاور مختلفه وهي تتمركز في عدد من
احياء المدينه
وشوارعها الحديث يدور عن اليات عسكريه
اسرائيليه كثيره اقتحمت مدينه نابلس وا
تجري وتسير هذه الدوريات الان في شوارع
المدينه وكذلك مدينه رام الله
عفوا مدينه جنين شمالي الضفه الغربيه ايضا
تتعرض لاقتحام اسرائيلي واسع في هذه
الاثناء حيث اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مدينه جنين من محاور عده
ومختلفه وا حاولت او لا تزال تحاصر عمارات
سكنيه هناك وتدور اشتباكات في بعض الاحياء
داخل مدينه جنين في هذه الاثناء وكذلك
تسمع اصوات الانفجارات مما قد يش يشير الى
ان عبوات ناسفه يلقيها مقاومون فلسطينيون
وهي عبوات في العاده محليه الصنع تجاه هذه
القوات
وكذلك تطلق القوات الاسرائيليه القنابل
والرصاص الحي باتجاه الفلسطينيين اذا قبل
قليل انسحبت القوات الاسرائيليه من رام
الله لكن قوات الاحتلال ايضا في هذه
الاثناء تقتحم مدينه نابلس من محاور عده
وكذلك تدور اشتباكات في عده احياء م زيه
في مدينه جنين شمالي الضفه الغربيه واضح
جدا ان تصعيدا كبيرا يمر تصعيدا كبيرا في
الضفه الغربيه من قبل قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي هذا المساء